[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here so this is
a fun one a couple days ago xiaomi gave
me a first look at a prototype
smartphone that they've been working on
so similar to some things we saw at ces
this isn't a real phone with a price tag
that has a shipping date or anything
like that this is just a functional
prototype to show a cool idea they had
and that idea is what would happen if
you took those curved edge displays and
just curve them right over the back
all the way around to the back of the
phone so you're just looking at full
110 screen and that is how we arrived at
this the xiaomi me mix alpha prototype
also before we get into it shameless
plug the merch is now permanently back
so a lot of the stuff you can now just
get whenever you want which is awesome
shop.mkbhd.com first link below the like
button that's pretty sick
all right let's get into the phone
so this is that xiaomi mix alpha and it
doesn't look like any other phone i've
ever seen before and i've seen a lot of
phones so you might remember their mix
line for a while has been that line of
phones where they really pushed the
design to the limits the first me mix
was one of my favorite phones for that
reason so that's why this one got the me
mix name and it's definitely no
exception the materials the specs and of
course the display are pretty next level
so there's the frame of the phone which
is this titanium alloy which is harder
than stainless steel and the camera
covers are all made from sapphire and
the camera strip on the back here is
ceramic i don't have a mohs pick handy
or anything but i tend to believe that
because this phone is heavy like it's
clearly dense and has a lot of extra
material extra glass for the screen etc
and the specs not that they matter but
they are pretty high end which shows
that they didn't have to sacrifice too
much to make this form factor happen so
snapdragon 855 plus 512 gigs of ufs 3.0
storage 12 gigs of ram and a 4050
milliamp hour battery that's pretty good
if anything you'd maybe want to see the
battery even bigger but a lot of that
space as you can tell is going to be
taken up by the screen wrapping around
inside the phone
and it does have 40 watt fast charging
which i will definitely get back to in a
second so clearly the focal point of the
phone here is this screen i mean just
imagine seeing someone in person using
this display where you can see it from
the front from the sides and from the
back uh this is a 2088 by 2250 oled
display with a very thin top and bottom
bezels that wrap around to meet the
camera strip at the back which is what
i'll call it this houses a couple of
things including the 108 megapixel
primary camera the 20 megapixel ultra
wide with macro capabilities and the 12
megapixel telephoto camera and dual led
flash and this phone also even has an
in-display fingerprint reader
impressively and it's 5g enabled and
there's a whole bunch of optimizations
in xiaomi's miui alpha software like the
battery and status bar icons and
notification counter are on the side of
the phone here instead of at the top so
it kind of cleans up the top to just be
a notification pull down and not have to
display all that stuff all the time
which is kind of neat and it's also just
like
crazy no matter what angle you look at
it it just doesn't look right like it
doesn't look like a real phone it looks
futuristic before you even think about
any of the sort of practicality
trade-offs also i told you i would
mention the charging again
i think probably the coolest part of
having a wraparound screen like this is
the charging animation so go ahead and
plug this phone in with the screen off
and the whole thing lights up and
animates the battery starting to fill up
the whole thing like liquid like liquid
power flowing into the phone
i love this and it doesn't stay on the
whole time you're charging that'd be
kind of annoying at night but it is
pretty damn cool you got to admit and
notifications will also do the same
thing they'll sort of glow all the way
around the screen which is super cool
so
seeing this phone on video is pretty
sweet and that's one thing but actually
holding it in person and considering
using it
is a total different thing and it brings
up a lot of questions so now that i've
actually held it and sort of used it i'm
here to answer those questions so first
off number one
just
what does it feel like to hold and use
and so to that i'll say like i mentioned
earlier it's heavy but what's funny is
it isn't as slippery as some of those
other glass phones like it seems like my
finger is grippy with the display glass
better than it is with some other
materials and just overall it feels like
well you're holding all screen so the
immersion factor is very real and then
you might be wondering hey wait a second
where are the speaker and the selfie
camera up at the front
great question two different answers so
there's a regular speaker at the bottom
of the device still
but for your phone calls that earpiece
is replaced by an electromagnetic
speaker basically that's vibrating
through the glass to create sound we've
seen this in previous mix phones and
there is no selfie camera at the top
instead when you hit the selfie button
you then flip around the screen to take
a selfie
with the main 108 megapixel camera now
weirdly the the selfie mode doesn't let
you switch to ultra wide or do nearly as
many things as the main camera modes
which is a bummer but in theory this
whole flip action takes your selfies to
the next level because they're coming
from the high end main camera so all
right then
how good are those virtual side buttons
on the screen
okay i'll preface this by saying it's a
prototype
but they're pretty bad i mean the idea
is fine in theory so there's a power
button and a volume button on the right
hand side of the screen on the side and
when you hit that volume button and you
get it just right while it's rejecting
the palm touch all over the rest of the
screen but it's realizing that you hit
the volume button
it pops up this slider and then you can
adjust the volume on the front no
problem by sliding but it really only
works for me
sometimes like maybe there's a trick to
holding it just right where you learn
over time
how to get familiar with the palm
rejection whatever it is
but i didn't arrive at this so this was
a bummer but then there's the power
button on the side that literally just
puts it to sleep that one worked more
often for me which is nice and there's
also still a physical
circular power button at the top of the
phone for sleep wake
that one always works but it's also more
of a reach since it's way up at the top
of the phone okay so how good is the
palm rejection or recognition on a crazy
screen like this
it's hit or miss as you might expect so
xiaomi dropped off a little info sheet
with this phone and on it they say
they're using a combination of
accelerometers gyroscopes pressure
sensors and software algorithms to be
able to tell when you're holding it
versus when you're actually using it and
to properly do palm rejection to me this
seems like the biggest challenge for a
phone with a wraparound screen there
were definitely times that it
impressively worked just fine but i also
in tons of other times using the phone
had tons of accidental presses not
including that software volume button so
it's hit or miss it's impressive when it
works but it's really annoying when it
doesn't and then what's the back display
even good for what's the point
well they've so far come up with a
couple cool things that number one is
the charging animation that i told you
guys about already i think that's pretty
sweet maybe the number one cool factor
and then there's the fact that it takes
the stuff from up in the top bar where
it typically is and puts it on the sides
to keep the front looking even more
clean at the top that's all right the
camera viewfinder is also a legitimate
benefit so we've seen it before that
using the main camera as your selfie
camera typically gives you better
selfies so you still get that benefit
and then there's the special software
mode where it detects when you flip over
the phone and it activates this panel
with some widgets that are a sort of a
quick access type of thing so there's a
timer in there the weather stuff like
that that's pretty cool too and then
just
looking cool
like that's that's mainly it it just
it's pretty sweet to look at oh also
another question is there a case for it
yes there is i forgot to take video of
it but i can show you this photo it
literally only has a camera strip to
anchor on and then it sort of sort of
protects the outside but not really i
don't even know why you would put this
phone in a case to be honest just accept
that you have a super delicate phone and
then i want to point out that this
display isn't flawless not to be a
downer but just like when you're working
with a prototype you naturally find a
lot of things that could be improved and
this was the biggest
illusion breaker of the whole thing was
the the edges of the display so right at
the apex of those sides where it's
rounding over the side there's a gap in
the cover glass so it's not all one
curved piece of glass there's actually
three pieces that sort of connect
together but when you run your finger
over that apex you can feel it so it's
not perfectly smooth and then from
certain angles it even catches the light
and rainbows a bit and you can really
see it so that definitely takes away
from the wraparound display illusion
there's also a fair bit of yellowing at
the very edges that you can sometimes
notice if you're looking for it the
camera doesn't pick it up as well as
your eyes and also this sucker wobbles
like crazy on a desk but that's i guess
unavoidable there's no other place for
it to lie flat the camera bump is
literally just a stripe down the middle
overall though i gotta say i'm very
impressed by this functional prototype a
lot of the numbers on paper i don't know
if i can really give them full credit
like they say it's a 180.6
screen to body ratio but there's still
bezels at the top and the bottom 2.15
millimeters to be exact so i don't know
if just because you wrap it around the
sides you can say it's over 100 screen
to body ratio and also what's funny is
on paper the spec sheet again they
mention uh they say it's a 7.9 inch
diagonal screen
but it's not that big they're measuring
it from around the back corner to corner
of the display
but really it's more like the size of a
pixel 4 or an iphone 11 pro max
but yeah that's about it in this world
where we have crazy concept cars i'm
glad that we also get to have these wild
form over function concept smartphones
and maybe that idea turns into something
someday so let me know what you think of
the wrap around display concept in the
comment section below would you grab
something like this would you want a
phone that's that crazy or is this
completely over the moon form over
function no reason to exist let me know
what you think
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace